và các bạn sẽ chỉ vừa xin.
Giám xác của Thay Kong của Chá Mẹ,
có này thì các bạn thấy cho một trường này học thì hồi,
các bạn sẽ là người chủ đồng.
Các bạn lực lửa trọng là học được người trọng
môi trường học tập, các bạn lực lửa trọng thơ dễ không?
Đến tiến vì vậy các bạn sẽ không toàn chủ đồng.
Và những như các bạn không dữ vượng các bạn thấy của mình,
thì không chắc một điều các bạn các bạn sẽ lực dễ bị sang á.
Để chính địa và chúng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụng tụi,
cho các bạn nê tư hoặc nào để giúp Chị Phạm có thể không,
cái bụng tranh còn thế hơi.
Để các bạn có thể hiểu được chứ một dựa để học của chúng ta,
nó sẽ nghĩ thế nào và thể là chúng ta sẽ khói kích thành một tranh v와 sắp.